he's got the support of a former beloved
bachelor he was shaking his trailer
shows an unprecedented moment for the
series but does our new bachelor have
you on his side it's time for roses and
rose a hi everybody I'm Lauren Zima and
this week I'm trying not to disappoint
you okay guys I know I know I know last
week it was shocking you guys I don't
have any rose day it was appalling
it was unacceptable and I'm calling
myself out just like you called me out
last week I didn't have any Rose a so
inhale and exhale everyone this week I
will not disappoint I went out and I
bought this on clearance for $4 at
Marshall's because that's how I spend
most of my money you could do so much
better and I got this it is an extra
large design wine glass which claims to
hold an entire bottle of wine so let's
be a focus group shall we from no Rose a
to a whole dang bottle
I can't believe that this is heavy oh my
god
oh it's the pink drink that makes me
think everybody it's back in my life
Rosie this is a darker Rose day than I
usually drink and I probably should have
washed this glass but you know down the
hatch hmm
oh it's interesting
oh it's fruity okay sure
because I spent four dollars on this
extra large wine glass which flips up to
its promise of holding an entire bottle
of wine I had to go cheap on the Rosie
and drink one that someone gave me don't
fight what's free
anyways I might feel okay about this
Rose Day but how do you feel about
colton's everybody I keep an eye on the
comments on our videos and some of you
are still feeling a little iffy about
colder of course when Colton Underwood
was first announced as the bachelor
bachelor nation was in sort of a tizzy
we always are some people wanted other
people like Jason or Blake and some
people did want Colton and at the end of
the day you know what wooly one is a
good show but because some of you are
still questioning Colton's such as Elyse
who says he's literally only the
bachelor because he's a virgin there's
no other reason good guy but not
Bachelor material Sophia who is saying
so not excited for Colton as the next
Bachelor
Oh barf Wow and Karen who spells her
name interestingly and says not my
bachelor first season ever I'm skipping
Oh Aaron with an I don't say that
because some of you are still
questioning Colton this week we are
doing an in defense of Colton Underwood
as The Bachelor yes everybody I am going
to take us through a point-by-point
because I'm the child of two lawyers why
Colton season will be a great season of
The Bachelor ladies and gentlemen of the
jury what I need to tell you won't take
very long at all point one Chris
Harrison supports him here's the thing
after interviewing Chris a fair amount
at this point I will say guys he doesn't
get overly expository if he's not really
believing something like he'd probably
just stay a little quiet on Colton if he
didn't think Colton was gonna be a good
bachelor but Chris has said all kinds of
great crap before we knew Colton was the
bachelor I interviewed him about his new
restaurant in Dallas and of course I
snuck in some bachelor questions that
interview was exclusive and at the time
he said we look at a lot of things when
picking the bachelor and good TV and
good story is a lot of it Colton has all
that in spades
there's the is he ready for this angle
the Virgin angle we have this guy who
was brought to tears during mento all if
he's willing to put that on display as
the bachelor I would find that
fascinating fascinating Chris Harrison
says mm-hmm he didn't see him saying
fascinating about you-know-who did you
if he did prove me wrong
somebody find
but I don't remember that don't remember
that quote and we have talked to Chris
several times since Colton was named The
Bachelor here's some great crap he said
cold is going to be good TV and that is
the reason we chosen Colton is going to
be a good story good TV he looks like
The Bachelor he probably won't have his
shirt on after night one so it's going
to be a good season that's going to be
part of the beauty of this of the
journey and of the show is that is he
ready he says he is he thinks he is but
is he and I think that's the whole point
of the show is that we're gonna find out
and by the way maybe at the end of it
he's not and it's a complete disaster
that's the way it goes that's life
that's kind of the beauty of the show so
those are points one a and B and stuff
great thesis statements remember you
know what drink every time you feel like
you're right in a college paper what do
you guys think this Chris speaking about
Colton the way he usually speaks about
the lead or does he seem especially
confident in what Colton is bringing to
the bench on the table that's our table
that's covered in cocktails I'm not
drinking for any other reason other than
that I got to get through all this Wow
I kind of did a shameless plug for
myself talking about getting that
exclusive interview with Chris anyway
what do we have now of course seen the
first trailer for Colton season we
talked about it last week and I think it
seems to live up to what Chris said we
see Colton in tears she's bringing the
tears we see him talking about his
virginity you could use your virginity
this week like Chris said that's a
fascinating angle you can't pass up a 26
year old full-on Virg and everybody it's
just interesting and we even see Colton
jumping a fence
my god it's impressive I thought the
truth you can't handle the truth
point number two I just spoke to Ben
Higgins exclusively shameless plug and
he revealed to me that not shockingly he
will be on Colton season of The Bachelor
families and Denver Colton lives and
Denver they filmed in Denver do the
bachelor math he's there and then I have
always loved interviewing he like Chris
really says it like it is and Ben said
of Colton season quote it's outrageous
when I got a sense of from my time on
the show is that this season is going to
be more genuine raw and vulnerable than
any season in a long time drink every
time Chris Harrison or Ben Higgins said
a bachelor catchphrase genuine raw
vulnerable and that was three drinks Ben
also told me he's going to be growing up
in front of our eyes becoming a man
doing this for love mmm that's a
bachelor phrase doing something for
himself for the first time in his life
all these things are huge stepping
stones that a lot of us have done over a
period of time and I think Colton's
doing it in a period of three months I
remember thinking when I was watching
Colton on Bachelorette and bachelor in
paradise there were two moments that
stuck out to me other than all his tears
because look his tears speak for
themselves and made me think okay this
guy could be a good leave because he
just brings it emotionally
we never really saw Jason and Blake cry
I'm sorry guys we didn't if you can't
bring the tears then don't be on the TVs
that wasn't my best upon work anyway
Colton's moments during the Bachelorette
he said my dad and I have a coach player
type relationship that his dad and him
had kind of a coach player relationship
I found that to be interesting and
during bachelor in paradise he said that
my whole life that's all I want to do is
please people
and the only person I murdered is myself
wanna stuff to unpack there I think
there's more to Colton than half meetin
the past if I show you okay this isn't
my best research paper yeah the writing
could have been better so far we're to
beat - okay I believe there is justice
in our hearts
point number three am I only on 0.3 what
period of the class day is it sixth is
it lunch
are we in P anyway point three Bachelor
alumni are just as fired up as bachelor
nation yes look at all these things that
people have said to us I think he's
never gonna probably cry the most out of
any bachelor in the history I was
surprised by the choice but I also think
like unto Ben's point there's I mean I
get why they picked him it'll be
interesting you know but you know Cohen
by his own admission has mentioned that
he's got a very limited dating life you
watch Colton season of course to be a
dumpster fire of course they're gonna
watch I think it's interesting because
sometimes when it comes to a lead like
with excuse you today I'm not sure that
bachelor alumni had a time to say about
it but they're in on cult and they all
know Colton there's more recently on our
television son you
Oh point number four puppies and
children look I'm not a puppy person
sorry
nor a child person sorry but a lot of
people are so I think that it makes
people like Colton and I think it gives
him a warm heart and I will say that
Colton's always been nice to me and I
like interviewing him and so you know
what I like a likable human I don't like
dogs and children I'm sorry I've no use
for babies anyway biceps I am a bicep
person and Golden's got some great ones
I sure it's not really gonna beat their
credit are they working out anyway love
a bicep loan Chris Hemsworth for that
reason don't get off on a tangent Lauren
golden golden those great biceps and I'm
excited to watch them don't shake it I'm
not done yet with the atoll think so you
can understand this now point number six
okay guys this is so interesting to me I
talked to you last week about the moment
in the trailer where Colton is hugging
someone who I said looked like a
producer and saying he's scared well
guess what I asked around to since
production sources and yes confirmed
that is a producer in the green jacket
so why is Colton hugging this producer
crying saying he's scared
I think the cult makes some kind of big
reveal or has some kind of big moments
on the show and I am so excited to see
what that is
combining that with Ben's saying that he
thinks this is going to be a very
genuine and raw season I'm interested
I'm really ready for the show to dig in
take us to a real place even if some
people are questioning whether Colton's
ready for love and for marriage what we
do know about this show is that it takes
people on wait for it a journey drink
every time I say bachelor please I don't
care guys I buy into it I love this show
we all have wondered why is Colton a
virgin at 26
what is that real reasoning and what
does it say about the way society looks
at men who's that hypothesis a thesis I
don't know what's the right literary
term whatever it is this paper is right
in itself I just jacked it up to maybe a
B+ everybody mmm wet like it's hard
bottom line points one through to a down
to 6b bring me to one conclusion I'm
super excited for Colton Underwood
season of The Bachelor and I hope you
guys are too what do you think did this
video change your mind if you weren't a
Colton believer have you been excited
about Colton the whole time did the
trailer or get you interested if you
didn't want Colton to be the bachelor
what do you hold onto what do you want
to see change let me know as always I
love you all
wow this wines really getting to me
I ate a lot over Thanksgiving weekend
and so I've tried to be healthy today
but no carbs means the winos running
right through me have I made any
progress on this where there's so much
dust on this wine that's what happens he
gets the phone of the clearance section
okay everybody you know I need I need
somebody to help Jesse this is the whole
bottle okay just come take one sip just
one sip for Colton
cheers to Colton and to all of you hope
everyone had a great holiday and drank
this much wine with their families love
you guys Jacy take us out you have to
drink the whole time I say bye one two
three bye
you know what okay by the way some of
you have asked about my status in the
comments and shipped JC and I I love JC
he has my work husband why am I doing
this with my hair but we are not dating
as I said he's single reach out to him
and I am also dating someone else so I
can't take JC and he's too good for me
let's be honest by E but does our new
bachelor have you on his side it's time
oh I shouldn't do my blanket thanks come
on Zima